hi there everybody so I do realize I'm
the last thing between you guys and
lunch so I'm gonna try and be as brief
as I can
we're gonna be talking about building
voice you eyes using JavaScript just a
couple of slides on Who I am my name is
memo that is actually my real name I am
from Mexico and I love sneakers so those
are three things about me if you ever
want to talk about any of those things
I'm available for that oh and I use
JavaScript weird so I don't make
webpages I don't know a lot about
client-side JavaScript my whole
experience with javascript is node
server list for voice when I joined the
Alexa team I really hadn't ever done
JavaScript development I came over from
a different company that used a
different technology stack but these
three years have been an incredible ride
it's been a lot of fun I'm really happy
that I get to work on the stuff that I
get to work we like to use this slide to
talk about you is so voice you eyes are
a big thing for Amazon we really truly
believe in these we think they are going
to change how we interact with computers
what we don't believe is that they're
here to kill all the other user
interfaces you might have seen a lot of
clickbait articles at some point talking
about that that's just someone trying to
make a living out of your clicks so
we've all at some point used character
mode right we type something in there or
we've used the graphical user interface
most of us do web stuff web pages
definitely change the game when it came
to you eyes and mobile development and
react reactive design and all these
different things we're a big paradigm
shift so we've seen these changes go
along but I like to think about it a
little bit more like this where we have
multiple you eyes these exist but we
choose which one we use based on the
type of work we're doing I don't foresee
a future where I tell my
terminal to navigate to a specific
folder and then do NPM I - - save some
package right AASK - SDK from a language
perspective that is not how I talk and
also it is very hard to say and to hear
so there's going to be very different
user interfaces for very different tasks
and that's okay I'm just here to talk a
little bit about voice as a user
interface so the first thing I wanted to
talk about is how do Alexa scales
actually work so quick show of hands I
think I can see if I cover my eyes who's
built voice you UI of any sort alright a
couple a couple hands in there so you
guys are old pros I'm just gonna take
the rest of us on a quick little right
here about house voice skills on Alexa
work and the way it works is here's a
quick 10,000 foot view of it we got the
user on the left side we got your code
that you would deploy on the right side
in the middle we've got a handy-dandy
device called an echo and actually have
one up here and I'm gonna do a quick
little demo for you
Alexa start Cascadia Jas hi Cascadia Jas
it's almost lunchtime yeah okay so
that's that's a quick little demo that I
put together and actually if I tell it
to say goodbye right now it's gonna
explode there's gonna be an error and
I'm gonna try and live code that before
lunch so hopefully if demo gods are on
my side today so that's just some
JavaScript code that I deployed to a
lambda function hosted on AWS and it
just serverless code written in
JavaScript I'm actually taking advantage
of an NPM package called a SK - SDK
which is the LX SDK language that's
actually written in typescript but we're
not gonna ding him for that so how does
this actually working when I said
something to the device how did it
actually parse it I said something which
is very different than typing something
there
a good analogy for it is Ethernet versus
Wi-Fi if I connect an ethernet cable to
my computer I know that the data is
going from one end of the cable to the
other end of the cable if I'm connected
to Wi-Fi I'm transmitting radio signals
all over the room when they're bouncing
around that's why the speed on the Wi-Fi
at home is so crappy but voice is the
same way if I say something it bounces
are on this room and then it hits your
ears and then you do some natural
language understanding on it and then
you figure out what I meant to say Alexa
works the same way it's got a multiple
microphones on it and when they say for
miles
that's a phonetic spelling spelling for
for miles you are not too hungry that
your look seeing weird signs it's an
upside down Omega sign but that could
mean many things it could mean for
example for miles and we we parse that
based on a grammar and a language model
that I'm going to show you real quick in
a second and then we turn that into
everyone's favorite JSON so why use
JavaScript to build Alexa skills because
we turn all that language into a JSON
object and there's nothing that's easier
to work with than JavaScript and JSON
toads it should come very naturally to
you what we do is we turn what the user
said what we call an utterance into an
intent what the user meant what was
their intention and then we pass you a
JSON object that has the name of the
intent and might have some variables in
there so you can process that so or in
your code really all that's happening is
that you're taking some JSON you're
parsing it you're working with it and
then you're returning JSON that just
adheres to our standard and we do all
the heavy lifting for the voice
processing the natural language
understanding all these different things
is that a couple oh if this is a sample
of a JSON object that would be sent into
our code that one for example is in
Spanish so you'll see there's a tag
called locale and it's es - MX we're
very proud at Amazon to have support for
multiple languages I think we're at 15
right now and one thing to keep in mind
is you might see in the language
drop-down when you're
Alexus skill there's multiple English
models and people kind of tend to laugh
at it when they don't really think
through it because why do you need an
English model for Australia and an
English model for Ireland and an English
model for the US and an English model
for the UK beyond the just the acoustic
modeling of how we speak we call things
differently right so in the UK these
aren't pants right so if I tell someone
like hey you want to go with me and I'm
gonna go pants shopping it might be an
okay thing to do with my friend but if I
say that exact same sentence in the UK
I'm making a different proposition which
is do you want to come underwear
shopping with me and it'd have some
implications right so that's why we need
multiple language models in the Spanish
side I don't speak when I'm speaking in
Spanish like someone from Spain they
call shoes that I'm very fond off
sopla tedious that is what we call
ballet shoes in Mexico I would never say
that I'm into ballet shoes cuz I just
know I'm just not so it's it just Forks
and it grows and grows and grows so it's
really important to have these multiple
language models so we can capture input
accurately and the name of the game when
it comes to voice is accuracy and
context so this is describing the first
flow at the top there's a bunch of
different really complicated math and
compute it compute that's happening in
there the good news is you don't need to
do it it's a bit of a black box but it's
a toolbox for you that we already built
completely free to use what we use is
speech recognition so we're trying to
turn the audio that we got into text
then use machine learning and natural
language or understanding to understand
the meaning of that text reading so if
you said blue do you mean the color blue
blue or the verb blue and it kind of
balloons out of there on the right side
there's just some JavaScript code and
it's all just working with JSON on the
flip side so if you're going on the from
the back we're returning a response and
we're saying the output speech is okay
and the type is SS ml and we're get
we'll get to SS ml in a second ss ml
stands for speech synthesis markup
language you can think of it all
most like CSS for voice so when you
heard Alexis say YUM
it put a bunch of emphasis into that I'm
using SSM l to markup my speech when I'm
returning it to to our ears basically so
what it's doing here is gonna take that
object find what the actual output
speeches and then it'll say it and again
that's a phonetic spelling for okay and
that's what we'll hear and then
hopefully we'll try to our human brain
will parse it properly
so just final reminder of last time
we'll see this guy and it's that
everything that's happening at our
communicating with our service is JSON
and all our code is JavaScript
it's ghosted on AWS for in my case using
serverless technology which is lambda
but you could build an HTTP server or if
you already have an HTTP server and just
direct the traffic there do all your
processing there send it back there's no
real language requirement we just love
javascript and we've built this amazing
as a kay but we also have a bunch of
samples out there and all these
documentation specifically for
javascript so it should be very easy for
you guys and gals to get started today
so I'm not gonna bore you too much with
that I just want to talk a little bit
how you build one of these and like any
other piece of software it's gonna have
a user interface and a programming logic
so a front end and a back end except the
front end is like ear end and voice end
right because what you're saying what
you're hearing and the programming logic
is just gonna be some code in the
specific demo that I'm gonna do I'm
gonna build all my voice UI using
developer amazon.com and then I'm going
to close my logic in AWS quick quick
quick reminder what we're going to be
doing when we're building a voice UI and
I'm going to show you one that's
pre-made is we're gonna take uh pterence
is the different ways someone speaks and
then map those to an intent the intent
is just a flag then I then
look at in my code and say based on this
event I want to run this code but it's
what we're doing is we're training a
system we're using artificial
intelligence ml natural language or
understanding so I put a bunch of
utterances into a funnel and those get
turned into an intent and then in my
code I'm going to actually handle those
and I'll go walk line by line through
this code in a second but you got to
remember most important thing probably
out of this whole talk is garbage in
garbage out so you're training a model
if you put in a bunch of useless
training data it's gonna behave wildly
and erratically and do all these things
that you don't actually want it to do so
you got to be really mindful of what
you're training your model to do when
you're training the model you're not
building you're not creating an array or
an enumeration of sentences that the
user can say you're giving an array or
an enumeration of sentences to a machine
and it's going to try to build a grammar
and a language model out of that so be
really careful about what you what
you're doing if all your sentences end
in the word please what you're teaching
the model is to look for sentences that
end in the word please so variety
looking for different adjectives
different verbs talking in plural
there's a singular that one I learned
from my mom because she kept breaking my
skills so I'm gonna do a quick demo and
I'm gonna show you what I built to do
that really really basic skill that I
showed you and of course I'm logged out
and what easy fix okay so what I did is
I created an intent that was called
called begin intent in a skill called
Cascadia Jas I actually ran into an
issue because Cascadia Jas is hard to
say it's a made-up word so I have to
split up into Cascadia which I didn't
have any issues capturing and then Jas I
did it two ways Jas has two letters and
the
jas as an initialism which is je period
s period FBI is an initialism it's not
really an acronym an acronym is when you
can say the word aloud and of course I'm
blanking out right now oh yeah NASA NASA
is a good one thank you
so in this case I did it both ways this
should be just but it still works and
what I did is I created these utterances
for this utterance and they're all get
started let's get started to start begin
my talk start my talk they all have this
they're conveying the message if I want
to get going and I could add a ton more
of a variety here what you have to be
mindful of is if you have multiple
intents you have to think of them as a
Venn diagram this should an overlap when
you're making a website or an app you
would never put two buttons that kind of
overlap and then the user clicks on it
you like I don't know what's gonna
happen exciting it's the same thing for
voice if you put the same utterance in
to intents you're gonna confuse the
model it's not gonna really know what to
do so it's gonna behave erratically I
also made a goodbye intent and a half
bye-bye goodbye say goodbye say bye in
there let me demo that real quick and
it'll just be an error because I haven't
created the code to handle it and we're
gonna do that right now
Alexa tell Cascadia jay has to say
goodbye sorry an error occurred so that
just my my back-end code saying like I
don't know how to handle this I got an
intent and I don't know what sorry with
it an error occurred Alexa stop goodbye
so it's it just it would have been just
cycle there with that error so what I'm
gonna do is go to my a Tobias console
and all I have here is just a lambda
function that has a trigger set up for
Alexa skills kit and has a dependency on
the SDK so let me show you that real
quick
[Music]
designer so this is just the AWS AWS
lambda console here I'm saying
it can take Alexa skills kit event to
trigger my code since it's server less
it doesn't mean it doesn't use a server
it just means that me as a lazy
developer I don't have to think about
the server I don't care if it's a
Windows box or a Linux box sort of
someone harden it or if there is a load
balancer in front of it it just does all
that magically for me which is great
because I don't want to spend my time
doing that and then looking at my code
really quickly you'll notice that I have
a few handlers they have a begin Handler
I have a help Handler and I have an
error handler and that's where we're
saying sorry and error occurred but I
don't have a handler for the other
intent that I created which is the let
me refresh this page to make sure that
my changes will actually do something I
don't have a handler for the goodbye
intent so it that's why just throwing an
error I'm gonna create that intent real
quickly and what we have here is I'm
just gonna steal my own code and turn
this begin handler into a goodbye
handler by content handler and what I'm
doing is this handler has two functions
in it when it's can't handle and the
other one is handle they both take a
handler input as a parameter and that
parameter contains a whole request that
we were sent from the Alexa service and
all I have to do is return true to the
event that I want to respond to so
instead I'm saying request type intent
request and then instead of begin intent
I'm going to change it to be goodbye
intent and I've known from doing a lot
of live demos that you should never type
copy and paste as your friend and then
the response here instead of being high
Cascadia j/s blah blah blah I'm gonna
just say
enjoy your lunch and then punctuation
spelling all those things really matter
here because if I screw it up it's gonna
say in or if I forget that my I'm
sending a response back that it's
supposed to be in Spanish and I type it
in English it's gonna try to parse all
those letters as Spanish and I'll be
Spanglish and it'll be hilarious but not
very helpful so now I'm just gonna save
that instance all deployed to the cloud
I can just immediately test it Alexa
tell Cascadia j/s to say goodbye sorry
an error occurred so this is where you
pull your parish an error occurs Alexa
stop and an error occurred so apparently
it broke everything what I'm going to do
is just show you from the simulator and
we can do a quick debug Cascadia J yes
so this is the simulator allows it to
type in things that we could also say
and of course nothing is working now
this is no one's fault but myself
that was a comma
okay here we go so once we see this in
the simulator we have the JSON object
that's going into my service on the left
and the response on the right and you'll
see that here's the one since I just
said open it's giving me that welcome
message but if I say open Cascadia j/s
and say goodbye we should get an error
that we can debug with so I have this
event and I can take this whole event go
back to my lambda function and configure
a test event here I'm gonna create a new
event gonna call it error and then I'm
gonna replace it there and I'm gonna
pass in this error this event into my
lambda function by passing the Alexa
service so I'm kind of spoofing it but
since it's my own account it's secure
and I can actually do that then I'm
gonna click test and I think I already
know my error which is my error that I
always make which is handler chain on
found yep
handler chain on phone so what I did is
I created the handler but I never
registered it so it doesn't know there's
a handler for it so I'm going to
register that handler this is what
happens in your live code copy that
handler and then down here at the bottom
with the actual SDK I just register that
I'm gonna save and test and now we
should just see that enjoy your lunch
message so it works I'm gonna wait wait
a second for Alexa to come back because
I unplugged her because he was looped
and we'll test that in the meantime now
that we've done with our demo and got
four minutes I just wanted to leave you
with some design notes about voice so a
few thoughts on design the first one is
friction is the enemy any time I'm doing
anything with voice I'm probably like
that awesome lady just hanging out on a
hammock by a cactus reading a book
but uh but what I don't want to do is
get up and touch something or find my
phone or whatever like I just want to be
able to say thing so if it doesn't pass
the couch test it's not good it's not
probably a good use case for a voice we
also don't talk the way we write just
ask your English teacher from twelfth
grade so anytime you type in something
that the user needs to say or that
Alexa's gonna reply just say it out loud
you'll be surprised at how good we're at
tongue twisters but you read them and
they're like that makes perfect sense
I'm an incredible writer where's my
where's my Oscar
the other one is follow the brought the
one breath rule if you're sending some
response back and it takes longer than a
breath to read out it's too much
information voice has a problem or a
it's not a problem it just a
characteristic which is it required it
has a high cognitive load and what that
means is we have to pay attention to
what the device is saying we can't
multitask with voice you couldn't
pretend that you're watching a movie and
also listening to a conversation but you
quickly context with Jing and you're
probably getting 70% of one and thirty
percent of the other so if we're giving
the user options and they're only
getting 30% of it it's gonna be bad so
be brief and don't talk at people talk
to people you know we want to model
something as a real conversation between
humans variety is your friend so every
time you call your bank or your airline
you get the exact same prompts in the
exact same monotone voice that is
incredibly boring that's also not how we
talk with humans so after have some
spice in there use SS ml say YUM when
you're ending your message it makes it
stickier it makes it memorable if it's
Monday say happy Monday or if it's
Thursday say it's almost Friday I don't
know just make it a little bit more
interesting designed for the situation
you can break down any step in a
conversation into four things the
utterance so what the user said what the
situation they're in is the first time
I've ever seen them is there's a 100th
time they saw I saw them where they in
the middle of the game last time they
talked to me and then what response on
them I'm gonna send them and what prompt
or what question am I gonna ask them you
can break down every single interaction
to this and then you can make awesome
little cards with those and start
storyboarding with them diagrams or
flowcharts are not a good way to design
a voice conversation because the user
can say anything whenever they want if I
call a travel agent I can and they ask
me where do you want to go I can say I
want to go tomorrow and they're not
gonna hang up on me and be like nope
wrong answer
so your skills should work the same way
it should be really really freeing again
friction is the enemy that is it for me
I just want to let Alexis say goodbye
Alexa tell Cascadia Jas to say goodbye
sorry I'm not sure that fun thank you so
much it was an absolute pleasure
[Applause]
all right bear with us for just one or
two minutes while we do little laptops
which I know oh by the way while I have
your attention for a couple a couple
moments I'll just go ahead and admit
that I can ask more specific and better
questions when trying to plan lunches
that is a betterment that we can do for
next year I would I do want to say
though if you did not specifically
specify a dietary restriction of
vegetarian or vegan please abstain from
those items when you go grab lunch I
know they're all delicious but planning
is tough and we just want to make sure
that there are enough vegetarian and
vegan options for the people who need
them but here we are and I wanted to
take a couple minutes to talk about the
closing party that we're having tonight
and the best person to kind of share
this event with you is Heidi Larsen one
of the co-organizers of Cascadia and
more or less the brainchild of the event
we have tonight so I'm going to turn it
over to Heidi hello hey I'm really
excited to hang out with you all at the
living computer museum tonight and if
you're not excited yet let me tell you a
little bit more about it because the
name doesn't communicate a lot it's a
computer museum because it has the
largest collection of mainframes super
macro mini computers in the world and
it's living because they all work and
you can use them so if you're not
excited yet
that's just upstairs Downstairs is all
the modern tech so interactive exhibits
with AI VR big data there's a
self-driving car there's digital art
there's video game making I'm forgetting
stuff anyway it's gonna be really great
please come to living computer museum
and have fun with us starts at 6:30
there's gonna be food and drink there
have wilt snacks and and then beverages
there and there will be a food truck
outside for anyone who wants to come
directly from
this event you need your badge to get in
you need your ID to drink and yeah and
then we'll just get to play there's
karaoke as well yeah if I forget
anything Carter will cover it okay
awesome thank you so much Heidi she's
worked really hard give her a round of
applause yeah this event is absolutely
gonna be amazing
I've told you a little bit about the
logistics I've sent you an email about
the logistics I asked you to RSVP so we
could get a head count a couple
logistical items one I think we're
absolutely cool for people to bring Plus
Ones
so up to you know we're not gonna turn
anybody away from the Living computers
museum so please come please consider
bringing a spouse a friend we just want
to share the experience with everybody
as Heidi mentioned briefly please eat
dinner before you come there will be
food there but more snack style
charcuterie stuff we have we there will
be a food truck parked in the parking
lot right outside the museum it's not
free you'll have to pay for it but the
it's not very expensive in the food is
super yummy I wanted to take a minute
you for those of you who joined me at
the opening party last night you know
you've heard this and I'll just say it
again like these events you know doing
buyouts like reserving these wonderful
amazing spaces exclusively for our use
so that we can all be together enjoy
each other's company and kind of feel
like our people are here it's incredibly
expensive and I just want to thank these
four companies for making tonight's
event possible Twilio misty robotics
Microsoft edge and Ezra's who could
please give them all a round of applause
alright anyway one one last thing do you
all want to do a little live demo a
little live demo it'll take two seconds
take out your phone right now if you--if
you know at the company I used to work
for this is not surprising you at all
let's test the Carter's karaoke hotline
please text your name your song and your
artist to two zero six two oh three
eight eight one one go ahead and do it
now I'm actually gonna go ahead and play
along
and let's see luckily I already prepped
something
see if it works this is of course where
demos fail
oh man huh ooh nice
Rasputin I don't know that so so these
are gonna these are gonna start to
stream in awesome so this is what's
gonna happen tonight
and but the thing is that DJ we we have
got the best karaoke DJ I've ever seen
this Ivan is amazing but Ivan is cruel
so Ivan will see things like I'm on a
boat and he'll click cancel and you'll
get it you'll get a text message saying
sorry Ivan doesn't like your song on the
flip side you know Ivan will look around
and he'll say he'll sees Oh fireworks by
Katy Perry call it up and we'll we'll go
ahead and click that button and we'll
call up your song so this is the
experience that we're gonna we're gonna
have tonight I I love karaoke I know a
lot of you do too okay thank you for
bearing with me I can't wait to see all
of you tonight now go have lunch
[Applause]
[Music]